it's like a
sunset of tuna The Producers told me
that I was going to be interacting and
eating sushi in some way the Rarity the
specialness of the experience was not
conveyed and could not have been
conveyed here we are in Tokyo just got
off the plane a couple hours ago I was
supposed to be on a beach in Bali but
National Geographic called the other day
and said uh cut your vacation short come
to Tokyo and now I don't know what the
plan is going to
be it's a letter and it's a list of
sorts sorted into categories it says
Dear Lucas in a residential neighborhood
in Tokyo Chef hasashi udatsu presents an
Omak menu with some creative and
non-traditional ingredients and cooking
methods that put it on our 2024 best of
the World list your mission find out why
by competing our scavenger hunt don't
forget to take photos as you complete
each task first things first test out
the camera
selfie mean mugg we're actually doing
this
[Music]
now first is to find udatsu
sushi ride the subway to nakame
station ride the subway
done walk along the canal and explore
the
neighborhood done bring a present to
give to the owner if you don't have one
purchase one
big Goods might be kind of
cute a
haircut maybe some tea got it I'm
holding the tea underneath my armpit you
just can't see it
done after the train
tracks They said you'd see it when you
see
it find new datsu sushi
done
I think there's something magical when
chefs meet each other mostly because
most chefs are so kind and so nice and
know what we go through within the
industry but more than anything we're
also Perpetual lifelong
students wherever we're eating whatever
we're eating whoever we're eating with
huge objective of ours is to understand
the
deliciousness very much thank you very
much I felt very much at home and at
ease with Chef because he was so happy
to to teach me I didn't
know I'm sorry to ask this but can I
take a photo of
you
done I cooked in Japan a while ago in
kaiseki but because I was very Junior I
was not allowed to touch fish so this is
like a very next level thing for me as a
chef I don't think I'm ever going to get
this opportunity ever again to sit in a
restaurant with a chef and ask so many
probing questions and meet a chef who is
so open to answering those questions and
and genuinely helping me understand a
little bit more about the evolution and
the movement of sushi Through the
Ages
this is ridiculous it's so baller to
start a meal with texture that you don't
anticipate when you walk inside of such
a Serene Omas sushi place as a chef
who's cooked in the Western World you
see micro beans you get scared because
you think that it's going to be bitter
it's going to be it's going to take
things away but when it's doubled down
on that in the center to such texture
and the oiliness of the fish plays with
the natural bitterness inside of those
greens it's such an unexpected first
step into a new direction I've never
started any sushi meal like this first
fight of the meal
done
wow the imprint on there isn't just for
show it's actually Smokey feel like it's
a call out to some of the Smokey flavors
that are going to happen
later when we look at a restaurant like
U Sushi a lot of people want to throw
the word experimental and new on there
but in our conversation with Chef one of
the most important words he said was new
tradition so how would you describe your
style of
[Music]
sushi learned about his cooking
philosophy
done it's GNA smoke I
think
m
God damn
it sometimes I wish I was acting but I
genuinely am
not I first of all I I've never had
Wasabi like that before why isn't it
spicy I was reminded that that's s with
Wasabi tastes like all around the world
most Wasabi that you get in take out
sushi restaurants is actually horse
radish that's dyed green and so it's got
an aggressiveness to it one of the cool
things that Chef did was bring in his
Artisan that had made a lot of his
Chopsticks table settings in this case
specifically the Wasabi
grater
W so what is this what is it for and
like why do we have to make it out of
the stingray
what
do you see that your philosophies match
up ask about his ingredients and tools
done andan was nice enough to show us
that process and to let me try my hand
at
[Music]
it you
good oh it's so um it's very green it's
very
vegetal the spice is momentary and it's
exciting and it's explosive but it's not
excessive great fresh Wasabi
done so I see Lotus
roots
particularly excited about this as a
Chinese Chef because um there's a
Chinese ingredient of the Chinese
pickled mustard greens but um when we
saw the prep of this earlier it's a
totally different um color it's bright
green instead of yellow I'm expecting a
lot of crunchiness a little bit of that
like silky sliminess from the nagaimo
and importantly the first appearance of
rice in this tasting menu
M
wow I love
this but actually out of this
world the focus that Chef has plus the
restraint he has to bring in new
elements there's something new going on
there okay here we go first piece of
Nigi Nigi
yummy a beautiful thing that I learned
about sushi today is that if the fish is
good the fish part is good but the rice
is perhaps the most reflective of the
sense of style of each sushi chef what
is your approach to um the rice
here
[Music]
it was really special that we got the
chance to see how that Rice was
prepared what you can hear now is the
rice alarm which basically is the rice
jumping up and down inside of the pot
causing the lid to
Clank at Udu Sushi shef Fatu makes two
types of rice one for mro that's a
little bit more Punchy a little bit more
acidic and the other for everything
that's not my
grow such like minute differences but
from the time the rice gets rest to the
manipulation of the rice all changes the
texture just so slightly so that when
we're tasting it like this it doesn't
taste like how it did with a fish but
eventually throughout the process it
will preparing the two types of rice
done something really interesting about
a lot of the things I've had today is
the the sequence of flavor and the
evolution and like the timeline within
the
M like something will come in and
there'll be one texture and there'll be
like a hidden little surprise in the
middle so
good in this case a sweet small burst of
sweet strimp in the center I haven't
seen before and I didn't know it was
[Music]
possible learn how to cut fish in the
traditional Japanese style we did not do
that it would have been inappropriate
given how woefully insufficient my knife
skills are however we did learn a lot
about fish Butchery and everything to do
with the
fish one of the most amazing things as a
chef watching a sushi chef is that every
single step is so neat everything is
squared off very aspirational
stuff to clear the air I
suppose I don't speak Japanese anymore I
worked in Japan for a couple years
picked up kitchen level Japanese which
is 50% grunting m M and then lost the
50% of grammatical syntactical Japanese
due to uh an ex-girlfriend telling me
that my Japanese is
bad learn how to cut fish in the
traditional Japanese style sort of done
not Chef also brought a second Artisan
he is the go-to knife expert for all of
the top sushi restaurants in all of
Tokyo
what's incredible about that
relationship is how well he's gotten to
know each Chef that he
serves how do you talk about knives and
how do you find the right knife for the
right
chef
[Music]
[Laughter]
for Meet The Knife Guy
done
[Music]
nothing prepared me for this everything
just collapses into a puddle of maximal
flavor the fat just melts and pushes
almost just like into a puddle all over
your palette then the rice starts to
come up into those little pieces that
you chew through little pop po pop it's
too
good
who the crab is really nice and sweet
yum try sushi from aini it's not from U
Sushi as a point of
comparison that okay so we found a NE
Toro which is a minc tuna with
chives
Mass produ snori has this like brilliant
green color but it just doesn't have
that crisp obviously that Sushi had the
rice doesn't have the same amount of
chew it's a little bit gluey and the
fish obviously in order to keep it
preserved inside of a Cold Case doesn't
have the same texture and actually
doesn't taste very much like fish not to
say that this tastes
bad just doesn't compare oh my goodness
I didn't take a
photo this photo is missing but I swear
I did it taste the convenience store
Sushi
[Music]
done
what one by
the layers of flavor again usually when
you when I've had sushi before and we
get to Oi they always ask would you like
this one or that one this type or that
type this has both one a little bit more
textural and buttery the other one
Punchy Punchy bright and sweet crisp
from the fried seaweed in the middle and
then that signature rice this is the
part of the meal when everything starts
to blend together because as the flow
picks up the Rhythm picks up
everything is just
happening and all our job as customers
is
to try to grasp what's happening to
us
what I'm sensitive to the word Fusion
because it implies a sort of crass
bombardment of Cuisine and a mishmash of
things in a way that is done in pursuit
of novel instead of pursuit of genuine
deliciousness whoa I'm so sorry can
someone translate what's happening right
now prawn row infused into egg yolk
sauce is that what it is tradition
informs Chef's
Evolution but what keeps him going is
deliciousness and there are also moments
of that
meal that are just sole like
purification level of just really really
really delicious things put together
like that egg yolk sauce with a little
bit of rice left in the bottom of the
bowl wow but I don't want to Discount
the amount of work that Chef has put
into understanding an older form of
sushi upon which he's building Udu
Sushi what wait
wa what the hell's going
on
what look at this I don't know if you
guys see it it's like a
sunset of tuna one by today
one I could try to say something poetic
like oh this is the bite that
encapsulates all these other bites that
preceded it but that just Ian that's a
ridiculous thing you can't not
experience that to know what that feels
like
than
wow what a
climax
whoa It's got plenty fish in it but it
teases out all that
sweetness it's fun and it's funny egg
for dessert like
this very
good
oh I think I need a moment to process
this the best tasting menus feel like a
journey because not only have you gone
from point A to point B like you
physically moved but then you can look
back at every single slice of that
experience and remember it and reflect
on it and feel like it all accumulated
to something like a plus b plus C and it
all like maximized into this big thing
and that's my feeling especially with
that um last M and then the the
T thank you thank
you on this list there are two things
that it asks of me one is to have a Zen
moment and the second is to write a Hau
about my
experience with my utter lack of command
of the Japanese language and a little
bit of help from our friendly crew
members I present to you the
[Music]
following it's pry good
done the takeaway I think from today is
that there is no sense of progress
without deep understanding of tradition
and Udu Sushi is a shining example of
[Music]
that at the end of the meal chef and I
had a drink at the bar next store at bar
Rock
show Cheers thank you very much thank
you for thank you thank
you how do you feel after cooking like
that I bet if I was cooking all day and
this guy made me keep talking about the
philosophy of food I just want to like
shut up can we talk about baseball or
something you
know finish this
drink done